tiger woods is back well not just yet
the golf legend tiger woods has shared
the first video of him taking practice
swings almost nine months after his car
accident the five-time masters winner
posted this three-second video clip with
millions of viewers already with the
caption saying making progress you can
see woods with a black sleeve on his
right leg he suffered serious leg
injuries after his suv crossed the
medium went across two lanes of traffic
and hit a tree in california almost nine
months ago he underwent surgery and has
been doing intense physical therapy
woods hasn't officially competed since
the 2020 masters espn columnist william
rhoden is here to talk everything tiger
and possibly a comeback bill good
morning
so what do you make of this video we're
all excited once we saw tiger out there
swinging again no i was excited too i
mean i'm thinking as a mercenary
journalist i'm thinking this is going to
be the story of 2022. you know because
i'm just thinking you know not much we
were talking nine months ago and we're
wondering down for the count is he going
to even live or walk is he going to walk
again much less play but you know
people like this people like tiger uh
brady jordan
you can never count these guys out
because it's a whole nother
consciousness you know so you're right i
would and i'm already getting my
credentials for 20 wherever you're going
to be
in 2022 because you know but it's just
really remarkable but what i keep
thinking though is
i've been covering this up for so long
and his chapters have just been amazing
his chapters from being at stanford uh
winning as an amateur then turning pro
then when the first major then the fall
from grace being a hero and a villain
yeah that was one of the steepest fall
of graces
ever and then you know to come back and
i think the lesson two for all of us for
young people is that you know we can't
undo you can't undo your resume right
yeah but you can add on to it sure you
can add on to it in a way that you keep
putting positive things there so when
you look at that that video that he
posted what do you see bill
is he is he sending a message to us well
i think he he clearly wants to play yeah
i think i mean he clearly wants to play
sponsors everybody else now kenny i mean
that's just the three right candy is the
question we said serious leg injuries i
mean he broke his leg in three places
exactly and he's got a sleeve there he's
doing rehab uh how when you see that
swing how close to golf competitive golf
speed is that swing well see we don't
a number one full disclosure i'm not a
golfer
to me tiger woods is golf right now you
know but it looked good it looks sweet
but i mean he's such a perfectionist
anyway but all that tells me that's only
like three seconds yeah that's not like
walking the course doing everything you
got to do
to be a competitor but i just think he's
letting he's letting us know that he
plans to play he may not play but he
plan i think
i will be stunned i will be stunned if
in 2022 he's not in somebody's
tournament yeah tony tony was talking
during the commercial break and he
mentioned how tiger played with such
power so the biggest question is if he
does get back on the course will he have
that same type of power but speaking of
power in a different sense
tiger has the power of changing the
complexion not just of golf right but
sports in general i know it's out of
sight out of mind when it comes to
sports but how much does tiger mean to
sports in general well to sports this
year but let's just stick to golf yeah
he is golf he's the face of golf ever
since he's desperate whenever he is in a
tournament it makes it all better yeah
and you know remember this people watch
they don't normally watch when he's in
me in particular to me it's like tiger
woods and even you know venus and serena
yeah you know they define their sport
and i think that as you know golf lives
on but it's always better if he's there
so if you talk about who are the most
hopeful people watching that yeah his
bosses
talking attendants viewers everything
goes up you think of who he is but it's
just
i'm just saying just in terms of a great
thanksgiving story yeah a great
thanksgiving story this guy could not
i i literally thought that he might not
make it yeah well i remember a lot of
spoke after the accident it was order of
operations was does he save his life do
that does he live
be with his family golf is third and
competitive golf is like hundred miles
away now it's flipped now it's flat it's
probably like competitive golf and that
you know i mean i think that
he's been playing golf since he was like
eight or nine years old i think the
sport defines him and i think he'll wake
up and sometimes even as a journalist
we've been doing something for
40-something years everybody
what am i you know what am i without
this people would love to see him come
back before you go can we just say
congratulations father of the bride what
was that like for you
watching your favorite daughter get your
favorite dog yeah it's still uh ryan
love you it's a role
being it's a whole new role you know
anybody who's got their only daughter
getting married
it's a whole new adjustment it's a great
great guy uh it's all wonderful but you
know the the the protector role has now
been transferred
to someone else but you know she's
always been my you know my favorite
congrats bill that's good thank you so
much bill congrats thank you thank you
for being here